[Music]
our message is to alert the
government and leaders to the
lifting of health restrictions
today many people no
longer understand why the
vaccine deadlock was in effect in France we
can't take the train from nice to
paris by tgv  but we can
move around very easily on the rer and
in the metro all day long without
any restrictions
what did we expect from this
operation
regain our freedom to show that
we are there that we exist that we are  human
beings and
above all canceled the ghostly arrested
two central vaccine copé this this
compulsory vaccination
wat pho
of political gains
in
serbia
[Applause]
legal adviser expectations to chekhov and
my body
squeezed that's there
[Applause]
[Music]